in 3d I am here on the study back lot
and I'm going to take you into stage 14
and show you where we film you for you
[Music]
hello welcome to the euphoria Basecamp
say hello Hey we're doing a Basecamp
tour this is the hair and makeup
everything happens you can see all the
pictures of different makeup looks that
we've done top strap doing take them to
the set cool they're working right now
so literally it's just like facades it's
crazy
usually we come here and everything's
already done setup yeah right let's see
it this is the map dressing room okay so
this is what they're building
yeah it's so cool can we take him to the
other stage oh we got our card over here
nope wrong cart going to this card over
here we're something episode 7 & 8 right
now swimming school stuff this is our
school and here we have cats holding
right now but sometimes it is set as a
classroom this cameras on both sides on
both guys so it turns 42 you Anna can
review what welcome to our school dance
there's three thousand stars up there
bring them into the balloon hall
this is the balloon halt dears when I
pose for a portrait click
you will see tons of people dancing here
music
[Music]
bye for now
[Music]
you
[Music]
you